area. Okay, good. Good. Cool. Let me let
me get it off anyway. So, the first um
area I'm dealing with is questions of
history and preservation. But obviously,
if I'm going to start anywhere, it ends
up being something fundamental. So,
obviously, as a Muslim, you believe that
the Quran is the word of God and it's
been preserved from time to until now.
Um so, when I was basically researching
this, um some of the challenges that I
saw and I found was actually
Um substantial what's that? Um the close
companion bel
um in their Quran before the time that
man actually compiled his own um they
had some uh strong variations in the
Quran that's not in today's Quran maybe
I want to know how that's possible. So
it was in
Thank you for asking.
I don't know if I can get it up right
now, but no problem. I can answer the
question about and so I'm not sure if do
you know what I'm referring to? Yeah, of
course. So surah 6 where I think the
verse refers to Aisha being the mother
of believers and then the next verse or
the next sentence was that and then um
Muhammad is the father to them
basically. So he says and he is a father
to them. That implication that work has
been removed and it's not in the Quran.
I believe because of the implication of
calling Muhammad a father to them which
don't say right. So no there's hadith
forensic say I'm like I'm a father like
you. I'm like your father cuz the
teacher is like your father. So there's
no problem but yeah. So so this issue of
firstly we have to lay down foundation.
Yeah. which is before points upon L
foundation is there is a creator you
believe in God yes okay
yeah if there is god and there is god if
the creator will not leave us without
clarify to us okay and the creator
because we can see his wisdom that he's
the most wise he will never leave us
with a corrupted teaching to follow or
to worship him he will always clarify
the truth okay Now, so we have the main
religion,
Christianity, Judaism and Islam. Okay?
So the truth must be in one of these
religions. The absolute truth it cannot
be mixed. Okay? It cannot be mixed. All
right? So now because otherwise if we
start doubting evolution then goes and
gives God's wisdom to
preserve to protect to to clamp the
truth to us also to uh uh for us to
worship him based upon pure and and
correct teaching. Okay. So now we look
to the Quran. Come to the Quran. Yeah.
There is many narrations in the hadith
which is over 19 companions of the
messenger of
Allah narrated and there's a narration
which is over 200 or something. Yes.
Yeah.
So so this one here is not hadith.
This is not Quran. It's hadith quoting
what has in Quran. Yes.
So this is basically so one of them is
Ysef Ali. I think he done a commentator
for he's a commentary for his own Quran
as well. Yeahse Ali Ali not really
accepting him. Yeah, he's not saying
that. I'm saying in in his commentary,
he notes out that in this surah, these
are the words that basically
had and yeah, I'm coming to it. I'm
coming to and also another one I told
you. He's another classical scholar. Um
it was in his famous book.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. Let me I'm going to
do every point that you're going to
mention. Cool. Okay. Some maybe you're
going to mention it, but I'm going to
cover it as well. So, you have to
understand
Sorry for sorry.
Yes. So, so to to clarify that what I'm
saying that you have to understand that
the Quran was revealed in seven
different ways of reciting it. See, but
this this is not even about the I'm
coming. I'm coming. I'm coming. I just
want to lay down foundation. You're
Russian. You're Russian. I want to I
want to lay down foundation to
understand. Okay. So mentioned and many
companies mentioned it. Why Allah
revealed the Quran several ways of
reciting it? Because Allah challenged
the Arab to bring the Quran. And that
challenge was not only for the people of
Qur. It was for other tribes. And the
other tribes had a different ways of
speaking of having communication of
using verbs of using a dua and other
things. So the fact that prophet
Muhammad wasallam Quran was revealed to
him in a different ways and he knew
every tribe in the penis how to
communicate and speak
the is why to give you analogy. Imagine
Prophet Muhammad. Imagine you now and
there's no internet, there's no
television, there's nothing, you know,
like 1,500 years ago, nothing. No, no
tools that you can utilize to learn
people's dialects. And you travel only
when you're young and you travel with
the people. You never want to learn from
someone yet you know how the Australian
speak. Even with a within Australia, you
know how they had different dialects,
different different accents or different
dialects. Likewise America, Canada,
likewise other English speakers won't
somewhere like that they can handle. You
never
traveled, you never met people and you
know how they speak, how they have a
dialect, everything itself if you can
know this very it's a miracle in a way
how you have that knowledge. Okay. So
the Quran was revealed the seven ways.
All right.
So mentioned the reason to make it easy
for other people. Okay. Now that civil
ways of reciting it, it was like
allowance. It's not compulsory for every
Muslim to recite the other ways. Now
with me now when prophet Muhammad
wasallam passed away and the Quran
before the was compiled in the heart of
the Muslims likewise was written in a
written form. Now when it comes to the
time I'm
skipp of all you to follow my way and
the
way they are rightly guided explicit to
follow them and also he's four people as
well. No, no, no. He talk about the
Quran he's more as well. But they're
more than him. But I'm saying in the
reference to one he says take and done
the Quran from four people. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. But
but there more than him. So likewise
like other so when they came together
some Sahabah they had Quran with them
and they used to write explan
explanation of the ayat. So I understand
the explanations and some of them had it
had it but this one here is not a
reference any notes saying the scholars
look into this firstly for you to
accept it cannot come with it he has to
come from a multiple narration multiple
narration okay and this conditions
multiple narration is widespread okay
that's why even when he said the Quran
it's impossible because why used to
recite loudly even some scholars doubted
Like there's a book I have some scholars
doubted this
statement about the attributes which
oppose the must they doubt is because
why the the the narration is not even
that strong okay like some of his for
example this one so so you're saying
this is not true so
did they or did not have extra words in
their Quran which said for example and
he is a father to them referring to
Muhammad in a verse which is not in
today's Quran today. The the this this
doesn't exist in anywhere by the way.
It's only through a a tradition that's
been carried on. For example, when in
their research other scholars have
written it down in their books and then
they basically um continue this into
tradition. So it's not from a book but
it's been already transferred. Yeah.
Yeah. And then they had it. So it's not
hidden knowledge. So a lot of people
don't know it for example. So a lot of
people don't I'm sorry. A lot of Muslims
don't know that for example in their
Quran they their Quran was different in
this this verse and this is only one
evidence that we have that I found was
actually quite strong. No, but what I'm
saying what I'm saying I'm saying this
this how did they after companions to
Muhammad at that time and he said it in
the hadith if you want to learn Quran
you take it from four people I think
[Music]
Madbas and there's one more two of those
at least I could see from evidence
saying that they had a line at least
which said Muhammad is a farmer to them
that is not in today's Quran that
contradicts the teaching today that the
Quran have been preserved from the time
of Muhammad
It doesn't it doesn't they explain the
history of the Quran like
there's not a
sorry it's not the mode of how to how to
um recite not who told you it's not
no you're missing the point means there
was some
abated you with me so so
you now no mean
So there were some Sahaba in so some
Sahaba had which was abregated
right then so they were abregated some
of them were explanation of the ayat
okay now himself agreed with the must
have of he took it back
okay he agreed because there's some
there's some commentary that says
conceal your mus from the humble and
arrest but he didn't want his wish to be
taken
away he agreed with why he was not he
did he did he did okay and now
Allah now we can all of them you
cannot greater than knowledge and he
said
because it's on explanation okay now
when you come to the Quran that we have
now we can trace it back to prophet
Muhammad wasallam
understood there's there's deep research
he said even there's no strong to go
back to some of the or the explanation
of that is attributed to him yes in the
beginning he agreed because he was not
he was not invited to for the Quran he
was quite vulnerable he said there's not
there's not he said there's not a verse
that I don't know where it was um or
take me take me to anywhere I know where
that verse is even when even was
compiling the Quran. He was he said,
"I'm against it because I know more than
this guy and this is the guy who
compiling the Quran. I know what I'm
talking about here. That's what he was
saying basically." Yeah. Okay. But so he
was happy but afterward he took it back
and he agreed with
Quran. What I'm saying is brother
imagine there's 70 people here which
prophet Muhammad praised. Okay. Yeah. He
praised Quran as well. Okay. He praised
Ali for Quran as well. So we have 70
people. Let's agree with one companion
logically, rationally, who should we
follow? Yeah, of course you do go with
the majority. You will go with the
majority especially if they met this
person and praise them and have strong
memory and they are knowledgeable. So
what I would say be like I understand
where you're coming from but I'm saying
you cannot keep using when we know even
like I said to you there it was not
only be able to catch okay and also this
was so um this will also be found in
another classical scholars uh commentary
as well. can bring you non- Islamic
historians orientalists who themselves
admitted that they even themselves
admitted that the Quran that the Muslims
have is the same the Quran they have
before but I'm not el of it who sorry
some non Islamic historians some Islamic
historian non Islamic non Islamic
historians bring them now that they
admit themselves but there's one French
okay and even her book the orient about
the doubt of
about he said it's he said I I want to
make it simple so everyone understand so
you're saying that the part I've noted
that for example in his pres companions
part when they said for example the
extra words the sentence and he is a
father to them are you saying that this
was not part of the actual Quran or this
was actually his notes what you saying
what you saying this is I'm saying it's
not true it's it's a it's not a a strong
um chain of chain of narration I'm
saying there's many that have been
attributed to is not is unauthentic and
some of it was abrogated. Okay, it was
what ablated and some of it is
explanation. So what I'm saying to you
that you cannot utilize even now
regardless which if it's authentic or
not cuz the and the Yeah. No, but
they're going to guess I know that. No,
no, wait. We guessed it. What I'm saying
if they bru over it as they like we have
we have narrations that followed the we
have a close student of that he followed
the so why I'm saying we have to be
honest why are we sticking to the old
stance and we leave the close saying he
followed the
no you your point is your point your
point makes complete sense alhamdulillah
then let's move on then okay the last
thing I'm going to say is
Go and we'll cut out something if you
want.
Yeah. Go on. Where's the I'm finally
moving on. But I'm saying in the
research which is brought up by
scholars, they basically so there's
another scholar as well. He's even more
of a scholar, but they are quite they
are quite certain that these words that
basically show that was part in their
Quran was actually part of the Quran
that was meant to be compiled in but
it's not into their Quran. The way they
put it, they were saying that it's not
just notes. It's not just, oh, you know
what, there's extra prayers or notes.
For example, had I think 110 suras, I
think was
it had maybe 114 and then that meant to
be extra prayers or some extra notes.
It's not even that case. They're saying
that in a sura
they say it's not abregated, nothing. I
can't believe that basically I've got it
here, but I can't do a word search. So,
because there's no Muslim scholar that
would tell you that
I'm going to have to get it the next
time I come back. But right now, it's
possible that what he's referring to is
abrogated. It's not the abrogated cuz I
know where the abrogated thing
was towards the end of his life accepted
Quran as man's mis it has it hasn't been
abrogated but it's actually it's just a
surah it's 336 it's a part of the surah
wherein that surah himself at the end of
his life to to the
the heed he accepted it there was even
though as well that was even after he
was put into incar
What's the complaint? So,
was it overlookated?
So, it was actually it was over the
comp. Was it to do with the version? I
think I don't know. It was his
version. Yeah. You agree? So, after
apparently he did. Yeah. But why why did
he tell other people to conceal his must
though? If if everyone if everyone like
his mus is with with his study notes
that he's if he wants to hold that study
notes but I'm saying yeah if he wants to
hold that isn't it strange though like
for close companions sake telling his
people in in
Basm Imagine you're in front of the
prophet you've got your notes written
down you remember the time the place
that's your personal record how do you
know you would you would understand why
he's going to hold on to if that was the
case
regardless he said his people to learn
the consensus of of the Sahabah that
accepted this man's he himself is part
of that consensus. Did I ask this?
No, I don't. I do. There's not much to
ask. Imagine you've learned from the
from the prophet himself. Sorry. And you
are sure of yourself that you know
that's what I'm talking about. You know,
you are knowledgeable. You know that
what you're saying is true. And it's a
small point. It's a small point I'm
talking about here. You are so sure
yourself that you are telling other
people do not take that other from
conceal your grave. See what I'm saying?
Do not take the other Quran. I said
yeah. So do not take the the from
from conceal your own conceal the to the
greatest. You're telling
them not obviously
after mention how many of generations in
the are Their changes need to be
investigated. For us, for us, for us, we
do not we don't try to explain a
narration before the establish authentic
or not. I know we
first the amount of uh different
narrations that are weak is so vast that
we're going to be all day um explaining
weak narrations. Are you are you in in
agreement that did have some
hang with these things? Check the issue
authenticator. Are they authentic? Can
it be really trace back as you mentioned
many things could be attributed to many
different that are not correctly
attributed to him. So even in
Americ scholars basically have said that
this although like you're saying like
cuz of course um as Muslims you have a
strict kind of science behind it. some
western some I can't remember the
scholar but I think it's paid from
sadiki I can't remember it's a scholar
based on the western scholar he's saying
that the consensus amongst scholars it's
pretty reliable to say that this did
take place obviously you can't trade it
back but he's saying that this is
understanding that in within scholarly
levels it's it's very understandable
that this even conflict conflict is is
well the conflict that basud had
initially uh when we say conflict we
don't mean physical conflict we mean
like disagreement initially uh that's
that's well known that's never been
hidden or anything like that when it
when it comes to these things. Now, was
there a disagreement? Possibly. Yeah.
Okay. Now, to get the actual wordings of
these things, you're using a specific
wording. Now, yes, there was a general
disagreement, but now to apply these
specific wordings, you need to
authenticate that. I get you. I get you.
But of course, I'm not the scholar. So,
I can't actually say this is the first
the scholar that I watch said that he
quoted this as well. He said that he was
told to he told the the people in to
conceal the mush and I basically exactly
I've never heard this in my life. What I
heard like I said to you go through the
story said just carefully. Yeah. I want
to I'll move on by the way. Yeah, I
bring that up. What else should I say to
you? what is known historically speaking
very close student
to they clearly said he agreed with what
also another point I want to mention
about remember there's which is valid
and everything but said argument this is
valid but the reason person allowed it
just as a allowance you don't have to
follow it now because some people are
misunderstanding it let us agree on one
of some which the must have can contain.
So we know we know every
of some of some of it is you with me
Kevin you know is review different way
won't still recite it
but said there's no need to recite the
other way let us agree on
this so they said they say what's the
fact the fact that we have in our our
sources that's why this is non-Muslim
non-Muslim historian
He said the argument that some of the
Islamic
I'm not word by word by the way but just
in the meaning he said the fact that he
said some non-Islamic orientalist
orientalist that keep trying to
utilize to say the Quran has been
corrupted is invalid because the Muslims
they spoke about it from the early age
like of Islam he said from the beginning
the Muslim they were speaking about in
their own works and everything so to use
against them doesn't make any sense. I'm
not trying to use it against you. No,
I'm saying you. Sorry. Don't
misunderstand me. He he was responding
to that's why that also like I said for
the Quran to be accepted first
condition after generation and there's
some which is valid but said with me I
get that there's been a before the Quran
has been continued there's been a
contend along the way there's been some
discussions about okay hold on some
companions had a different kind of and
I've brought up to you you said you know
what that's maybe some extra notes
that's that's been put away and we moved
Assam is valid.
Asamated is valid. Who who even get who
even allowed to be abrogated? Even after
the
problem no
problemation is only so that my next
point. No no no no. The the knowledge of
the abrogation may come to someone after
he's dead.
Do you get that? The knowledge the the
transmission that hang on this was
abregated once he might have met the
prophetam in his lifetime. He's reading
it what he what he was taught and later
on some and after the prophet's death
another sahabi would inform him if
possible that hang on it was abregated
but how how do we actually validate that
through the consensus hang on first look
at this yeah do you agree that the the
the of that is widely attested
to strong attestation so I from what
I've seen from actual research the eyes
have been preserved great it's been
preserved but whether it's been
preserved for the state that he says in
the Quran that we are guarding it and
basically it's word for word and it
can't be changed but whatever I've seen
is that actually you can point it out to
say where there's actually that's what
they came with we're talking about the
consensus of of the time from the time
of in the time of the two and then in
the time of what they were upon yeah
that final consensus that they all had
on the on the Quran from this moment
till now the Muslims have been reciting
this throughout the month of Ramadan
yeah in every of their salawat with
their I sat in front of one one scholar
for example and he has chain of
transmission I've sat with another in
front of another scholar who has 27
people in the chain of Quran from him so
these ej they're valid and they're open
and they're wide widespread now what we
what we need to understand is that the
Quran is established we're not we're not
basically we're not doing something
where there's where there's like we have
to dust off manuscripts and we don't
know who said this and We're trying to
piece things together. Firstly, we have
a strong starting point is
widely thousands upon thousands. When it
comes to this point about whether the
Quran has been preserved, largely it
has. Obviously, I'm I'm bringing more of
like a maybe an academic point. Oh,
guys, look look what I found. Look what
I found. I I'll have to obviously we
have we have the consensus of most of
every generation and then we've got a
narration in our passive inside. Yeah,
hold on. It's a small one. What brought
what is the foundation?
I need I need to bring the anti scholar
um that actually mentioned basically the
part that I was talking about in the
verse, right? And then it's been
basically carried on and scholar has
mentioned it. It's not widely spread.
It's not here today because like I said
the Quran has has been burnt has
destroyed which is I have to get the
scholar. He he's stronger. But like I
said, I've only for now then we can't
let's let's let's just go away from
this. Firstly, go away. Let's go away
acknowledging acknowledging that the
Quran from the reception as it has been
widely established with and unchanged
who is it from
I've heard I'm not sure
who we have now he took it from. So the
same. So that's why I'm saying the
clearcut proof that we have is the same
Quran. Like I said in the beginning,
yes, he didn't like it because he was
not invited. But some mention he was in
Kuba and the
collection was made in or did was done
in Medina. You understand? Yeah. So
that's why there's
many for
example took it from Ali and the the
first and the
same is the starting point. I would
understand you guys I'm not debating
that. That's fine. That's fine. But this
is what we want to this is what we want
to establish that firstly we start off
with this position that we have
certainty with these ones widely
establish with chains individual chains
of
transmission we have this to start off
with and now it's not just that we're
we're grabbing in the little bits of
information this is the starting point
established now we've got other
narrations that may conflict that so and
so we've got these narrations of
so no forget that one there forget that
one there forget that one that one that
Okay. Then the second thing you
mentioned is that we have it was it was
book
again again has many in the book in the
of there's many narrations in it. Yeah.
So, so firstly the main thing
alhamdulillah ibn hib mentioned that one
of the blessings that allahel has has
bestowed upon us in as this um is that
he has given us the isnad had it not
been for the people would be able to see
what he what say what they want and this
is specific to the um of Muhammad this
is does not exist amongst doesn't exist
amongst the nasal if the nasal had
anything like these weak
narrations of
of if the if the Christians had a
narration like this or the Jews had a
narration like this, they would be over.
It would be a day of faith. If we had
one of our weak narrations, our weak
narrations are stronger than and this is
no disrespect when we're saying this,
but this is the reality case. Our weak
narrations, not the not the fabricated,
but our subtly weak narrations are
stronger than anything that the
Christians have and anything that the
Jews have. So, this is the start point.
I fully understand you and there's a
strong case for preservation and I fully
understand that. I definitely vibe with
my kind of point I'm going at maybe like
the kind of intrinsic meticulous point
and I if I have to come back and do that
later anyway cuz I get you everything
with
with Islam a scholar statement is not a
proof rather it is in need of a proof
and a proof in this case I guess no it's
That's what we can support. But it's not
the proof. The proof for us. Yeah. This
is this is what's different to us.
Different from the the Muslims to the
Jews and the Christians. The rabbis the
rabbis amongst the Jews. Their statement
is is amazing for them. For us, the
speech of a scholar, we accept it or
reject it. We can throw the speech of a
scholar against the board. It's only a
proof for us when it has proof. And the
proof in this case for these narrations
would be an authentic chain of
transmission. And we examined the five
criteria for offensive duration. One of
them is that it has to be connected and
another one is there's many there's five
but the main ones that has to be
connected and that it cannot contradict
something stronger than it. This is a
key point. Narration cannot contradict.
This is very no it's very intricate and
it's very like at the same time for us
it's not intricate. Us our kids know
Bonia our kids memorize this. In
Moritania when the women are
breastfeeding the children they're
reciting with this these these rules
that we mentioned this is from birth for
the people of this is a whole session in
itself
what I would say is that with this point
here let me actually circle back on
maybe the point clearer in any case but
what I was saying when I was
watching one of them but it's a western
scholar his name is
I will answer your
question.
I think he's a scholar and his
discussion says that amongst his
scholars I don't know what he but just
in general in western academia there is
an assumption like an orientalist
assumption with um text you understand
the orient assumption they've come
through the reformation they've come
through the enlightenment period where
they found deep holes in their religion.
The these statements that Moses
apparently said, they're not really from
Moses. These biblical criticism that we
have about Jesus saying X, Y, and Zed,
we're starting to they started to see
these things are not really said and
attributed to Jesus. There's actually no
certainty. So these orientalists have
come out of this. They either became
atheist or they became Protestant or
they became double down and became even
harder Catholics. And what's happened?
This gave rise to orientalism. Now when
we're looking at Islam just there's no
way that these bed Arabs can have a
stronger text that is preserved with a
pure message of tohed that is better and
more in line with the more in line with
the clear message of the prophets.
There's no way that these bed Arabs have
the truth. So we there must be faults in
their preservation just to find it. So
this is the assumption the assumption of
of or western academia is built on this
oriented this kind of generally not not
first of all but generally built on this
kind of um skepticism of Islamic text.
But then after all of that the Oxford
University Press saying that the Quran
that we have now is the Quran that was
at the time of the prophet. So after all
of that skepticism they are still saying
that this was the same thing that we
have. So they're starting to agree and
and they're starting to catch up with
what the Muslims have been saying. The
only difference is that the unlettered
Moroccan uncle, the unlettered uh
Pakistani uncle who doesn't look the
most academic or most speak with the
best things English or whatever. He's
saying this now. It's about the the the
the humility of Western academia. Kandi
is better with Arabs be correct. And
they let's take one seriously. You'll
find you'll find one of the the main I
think it's gold. I think one of the main
orientalists. He went to Egypt. He he he
embraced basically Islam outwardly. He
followed and he said Iman had entered my
heart. He believed God was constating
these things and these were the early
orientalists. They admitted it. What
happened? They ended up going back to
Europe and they they uh they abandoned
everything. Yeah. It goldfer I think his
name is Hungarian orientalist. Look into
what's
an
L. But you believe in you believe in
God. Yeah. My bringing on the piston
about bringing Okay. So So then this
this subject is basically a side point.
Our main subject is that God has created
us. This all of this is a side point to
the main issue that we have that we
believe God has created us. God has
given us life. God has given us our
hearing, our seeing and all of the the
bounties that we are grateful for. And
so that it is a must that we worship him
alone without any partners. Now with
regards to you mentioned to me that
you're a Christian. Now if you look at
the message of Jesus that means that you
have within you in the Bible here. O
Israel the Lord your God has done. You
believe this when Jesus is teaching the
the the the disciples the Lord's prayer.
Our father who art in heaven. Hallowed
be thy name. Thy kingdom come. Thy will
be done. So he's teaching them to submit
to God. Now no now no now. This is this
is what we need to do. all of the
subjects. It's not we're not discussing
which car is better, which football team
is better. We're discussing the most
important subject which is the belief
that the path to God. So once we
understand that the once we have the the
path for God and we understand that this
discussion is the most important
discussion is there's some prerequisites
that we need to come to the to the
discussion and that is pure sincerity.
Pure sincerity in seeking the truth.
This is not an academic study. academics
they just but we're not just collecting
data. The reason why I do look at
academics now because of course like
every religion it's very political and
everyone has it going to bring their
evidence. So you're standing very
objectively at least at least you can
actually stand firm and say you know
what this is that and this actually
isn't
true. So no 100%. And I told
you I hear what you're saying. So
sincerity is the main thing and based
upon knowledge in your scripture as well
I think it's in job who is it that
darkens my presence with words about
knowledge you heard the scripture before
I think it's in job yeah who is it that
darkens my presence with words about
knowledge it is a must and this is we
have similar in our scripture as well it
is a must that we firstly are sincere to
Allah alone to God alone and that we
only speak of him based upon knowledge
and now this goes back to this whole
idea about Islan I can't just say the
prophet wasallam said something because
it fits with the argument that I'm
giving you now. I have to be able to
establish it. And it's the same with
Jesus. It's the same with Moses. When
anybody claims that Jesus said X, Y, and
Zed, I have to be able to establish it.
See things at the end of the day, we're
still humans. Who who's to say that even
this man hasn't even been fabricated to
say, you know what, I heard it from this
guy as well. And this man is only as
strong as your saying, listen, I trust
his brother.
understand then you don't then you
really don't know the system you really
don't understand system I'll give you an
example I'll give you an example we have
uh this brother Hakeim my brother here
yeah he's teaching us today yeah 10 of
us here 10 of us here yeah now all of us
we're on same level of kind of yeah now
we want to understand out of all of us
who are the strongest students of so we
have nine of us said that said ABC and
you alone you say that Hakee said his
biggest brother are the same he said X Y
and Zed. So you are alone in
contradicting 10 of his students. So
what can we say is that when we check
all of these we we compare you with your
peers. Yeah, we can see that you have
contradicted the majority of people that
and they're also trustworthy as well. So
we can say this throws skepticism on
you. Now another thing we have another
brother here Jamal. That's fine. That
makes sense. This is just one example.
We have another brother Jamal. I asked
him what was said on that day. He said
Hakeim said ABC. Now we come back to him
20 years later when his hair is
completely gray. And we ask him again
and he said Hakee said uh Z X Y Z
whatever. So I know that over time his
memory has failed. So I can now say with
precision that when he was younger in
London before he moved to wherever he
moved to he was he was he was uh precise
but when he moved to a certain place he
became old and he lost his books and he
started to muddle up. So this is the
level of precision that we have in our
chains of transmission. It's not just
it's not just Chinese whispers and it's
not just you're a nice guy I trust you
trust me. He's got it's not trust me
bro. It's not trust me bro. Yeah, he got
he's got Yeah, you got to verify verify
tangible ways to verify.
Let me let me leave. I'm going to I'll
probably come back. That's fine. No, no,
no worries. No worries. But listen, we
need on this. We leave on this because
we're not just here to share it. But may
the God of Abraham guide us to the truth
wherever it is. Can we say amen to that?
Amen. But let me I mean like I said if
anything I'd rather speak. No problem.
No problem and then go through a day.
Check check check these check the
references check the the chains of
transmission who from the Islamic
scholars have authenticated them and
then you can you can you can come back
and and discuss. Okay.
The will be here next Sunday. I might be
here
next let's have a at least I know at
least by